winter has come to Las Vegas the iconic
fountains of the Bellagio have been
transformed into an epic game of Thrones
experience complete with fire now the
production will run through April 13th
now in the final season of Game of
Thrones begins the next night on the
14th on HBO and fans of the series no
silly Turner can get pretty ruthless as
Sansa Stark but in the new x-men movie
Sophie does the absolute unthinkable et
on lines Lee Anne Aguilera let her
explain you're my family James no matter
what how does it feel knowing that
you're the one that got rid of Jayla I
don't know I think she was ready to
leave anyway so I think I just you know
I gave her a dramatic death scene mm-hmm
I think she was happy with it yeah yeah
it was fun is kind of nice it's like a
is quite an honor to be the one to kill
off this team I'm scared
when I lose control that deep zap people
we all cried when it was Jen's last
scene it was an emotional moment it was
also great we partied a lot after we
felt pretty good about it
Dark Phoenix marks Sophie's first
leading role in a blockbuster she
struggles to find her place among the
x-men but it's saying goodbye to Game of
Thrones that left her feeling stressed
well the Lady of Winterfell except bully
I think probably about like six or seven
months ago just after Game of Thrones
had finished and I went through a bit of
a wobble when ten years of your life is
suddenly like gone and you'd never be
that character again and I went through
a bit of an identity crisis therapy
really helped and now I kind of like own
everything the ending is a guarded
secret but Sophie told all to fiancee
Joe Jonas just not before he signed on
the dotted line Joe I didn't just tell
him Joe was on set most of the time so
he kind of figured it out and he was
like can you fill me in and he signed an
NDA and everything so I'm like it's all
good
[Music]